my vishwa karma
welcome back thank you so much thank you
for having me again
round two yes round two after two years
since
yes 2018 yeah yes good to see you again
likewise yeah and all the awesome
progress with
sukarma foundation congratulations thank
you so much
thank you as you've walked in and been
sharing with me
your update i've been just like yes
heck yes across all these different
incredible
aspects to uplifting rural india
yeah yes yeah we're gonna unpack
with visuals
all the progress that's happened over
the last two plus years yeah
a lot of lot of work actually yeah yeah
yeah it's a great experience like
amazing
yeah yes yes and for those that
want to learn more about especially
maya's journey that
led up to this point check out the
episode 1 the links in the bio below and
we will unpack mostly on this episode
the update of what's been happening over
the last two years with visuals which is
really exciting
and also you know sue karma foundation's
501c3 nonprofit
and so you can make a donation on their
website as well
and that goes directly towards all of
these efforts in uplifting rural india
and they're definitely one of the
top organizations that's actually doing
the impact there's so many organizations
that talk a lot
but the ones that actually do is
that's why you know that's why we have
you here
and that's why you know as we talk about
all of our projects
like with rich patrons that we're
working on unlocking the
six to ten trillion in high net worth
funding to then funnel
to these best projects around the world
that are actually tackling the most
important issues and uplifting the basic
needs
of people worldwide which then gives
them the opportunity to do things like
self-realization self-actualization this
type of stuff
it's so deeply aligned with our ethos
and so you're definitely spearheading it
in in india and specifically
in madhya pradesh
yes which is the center central
state it's the heart of india the heart
of india
yes 70 over 75 million people
in just the state yes
you can count many state over in u.s
yeah many states exactly yeah yeah and
so this is another thing is the whole
scales
phenomenon is a really important part of
this there's 330 million people that
live in the us
and there's one and a half billion
people that live in india
and so we're talking five times the
usa's population
and we're talking that many more people
that need their those basic needs met
and that will have
lots of really good again
self-realization self-actualization
gifts to bring the world
which is very exciting as well yes i'm
sure you're seeing this already a lot
with
the work that's being done with sukarma
where you're literally seeing an
a positive influence that you make on
meeting the basic needs of somebody
and then literally their time is opened
up
yes to be able to achieve great things
yeah pretty much yeah which is like
that's so heartwarming to see that yeah
absolutely
yeah yeah
yeah let's all right let's let's jump in
so we have
we have the visuals as well should we
just walk through it basically
i think it's probably yeah yeah it's a
good idea to go over the visuals and
yeah we can have an idea like what's
going on here so
yes yeah and maya had this maya and the
tsukama foundation put together this
really solid
end of 2020 email like the new year's
celebratory email recapping basically
all of the
awesome things that you guys have
accomplished and we also have the
so we'll pull that up and we also have
gallery images on the website that will
go through and stuff like that
so
okay
so
this is that message that we were just
talking about
and it looks like you've also had a lot
of
supporting hands how many how many
people is the organization at now
so we have 14 people as a board member
14 14 means seven over here
and others are volunteer of course and
in india seven
more in india so we have like these are
volunteers and
apart from that like we have other teams
which is
volunteer in the ground and our working
staff so
more about like 40 people 4-0 all
together
awesome yes so somewhere around
like 26 volunteers on the working staff
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah and there
are also some of them
people are on the payroll of the
nonprofit as well
absolutely yeah those are mostly in
india mostly in india cool exactly yeah
yeah
great okay none of them none of them
here we got paid like because
we whatever we get we really want to
give hundred percent
in the work we all are here volunteer
including me
yeah full time yes yeah
so
what was this first part the health and
care foundation
yeah so the story starts here as we talk
about like
you know all our work which has been
going uh in india
over like three four years and first one
was like you know as you know
uh menstrual hygiene uh sanitary pad
low cost manufacturing and then uh we
started uh
telemedicine center in the mid
afterwards when we had
interview and last year when i went
there
i used to connect like you know a
like-minded
non-profit locally in india so that we
can have more helping hands
so health and care foundation is another
non-profit
based in ahmedabad that's where the
gandhi mahatma gandhi
home was so that foundation works
very closely with the communities
in gujarat which is in western part of
india
and they they have a very big hospital
they worked over 30 years
first they were a polio foundation and
then later they become a
health and care foundation they had a
big doctor's team
and big hospital where they treat uh
very rare disease
at the minimal cost basically the
subsidized
treatment for the poor communities so
when i went to india our sukharma
foundation
want to introduce their foundation that
as a team
how can we work together so we had this
first meeting
in february first my first week in
february so that we can get
introduction of karma foundation and
then if we need
any help as a doctors at the medical
professional they can come to our state
and help us
in a bigger way which they have done
because in
uh in a year back we organized
one mega health camp in our area where
we
we treated around two thousand peop two
thousand patients and
we scanned 300 women
in terms of like you know the breast
cancer is is very like
prominent in all the communities
especially in india too
and in the village there there are like
many women they even don't go for
annual checkups or any kind of like you
know
just a routine like when they have
something so we had some kind of you
know um
a small device where we can take it to
the village and
scan like do the basic breast breast
scanning and then we find out if
something is wrong in there
and then if we had something then we can
report to the higher officials
where they can take care of them in
terms of the treatments or any other
helps
so their women community they are
unaware of any kind of like the pap
smears
or breast examinations or any other like
you know ongoing
treatment so we helped i mean they
helped us they
they were they their full staff was
there for
for about a week and then they went to
village to village and that's how we
we organized this mega health camp uh
before the pandemic actually
okay so it's kind of like taking really
strong
ideas from non-profits and intertwining
them
into one another's projects and so this
was about
the females health care
in terms of gynecology breasts making
sure that there's no
cancers and that kind of stuff keeping
good health yes
including also like the children's and
the older peoples because
they have all kind of doctors in their
hospital so
their doctors went to our place uh in
terms of like the surgeons
orthopedicians
and uh ents and all that all those
people
and then we collected the tribal
communities around that area
and they came all in the camp and they
got the treatments
so that treatment was free it was like a
couple of days
uh camp where we organized this together
okay okay so then
okay so now this is the
earliest part of the february
and then is this second
sort of or is this yeah so so this is
what
what happened like last year or when i
went to india
like you know i i i visit india twice in
a year
just a normal like you know doing the
projects and prepare like hey i'm gonna
go there and work in these kind of stuff
but last year was a really different
because in january we had no
sign or symptoms of kobe and when i went
there from beijing
it was kind of unusual that you know how
officials behind you how they were
checkings and all that
because we always hear the short of like
every year we have a new disease or new
infections or new something
but that not ah not big as as this
covered
so uh so when i saw on the airports like
there was big lines
and they were checking the temperatures
taking the histories and all
i have given and i went to the other i
mean other uh cities
and after a month i got a call from the
officials like hey
you came from u.s to beijing to india
do you have any symptoms like flu or
fever i said no i'm healthy i'm
i'm doing my work just going meeting
people and
all of the sudden in march
boom because you know everywhere is like
chaos and then
everything is shutting downs and
everything is like just
we had an indian festival it's called
holi it's a big festival in india
that's right yeah and people were on
vacation just you know celebrating that
stuff
and after the holi uh on 21st or second
march
rpm prime minister he announced
the entire complete lockdown in entire
country
believe or not like probably 50 percent
people even
don't know what is coveted because they
were living in a
in a very remote area they are mostly
the working staff
which goes from one city to other city
for the livelihood
for like periodically like four months
five months wherever they have a job
in march is a period where most of the
agriculture
crops comes and a lot of labor they
deployed all over the country
like all over the states like our state
we had a very fertile
uh state where we grow like all kind of
crops so that season was the
crop cutting season and a lot of labor
they deployed
into the field where they don't have any
kind of information like twitters radios
newspapers or anything and they've been
hearing this like hey
india is closed it's shutting down no
transportation
how would you go to home and there's no
limitation that you know
this will open in a week or two week or
a month or a year
no it's just like everything is chaos
then what we did is like
what to do because we also can't go
anywhere because
luckily i was in my village and then
realized
oh this virus is spreading like anything
so we need to aware the people at least
what it
is how this will spread
and what kind of you know where this is
coming from
how to stop this just to make an
awareness
because i worked in ucsf i used to make
a lentivirus
in a virology lab i handle all those
stuff i knew about it
so i'm the best person to give the
information
in their local language because they
don't understand english they don't
understand even the
the hindi which is like very very pure
because we have our own dialect with
which is which is like abundant so if
you can convert that
in your the local language and then in
local dialect
which is very very useful then what we
did is like
we prepared like the material uh
play the movies movies means like some
expert advice uh uh on a projectors we
played out in a
projectors handouts the pamphlets flyers
and and you know organize those campaign
you can see in
in the pictures like how people are
standing and
how we are managing those mics and and
you know going
street to street under the tree on the
road
and and so many villages idea is
just to inform that so that they will
not be scared they will not be like
you know uh they will not feel like hey
we are unsafe or something like that we
are going to die tomorrow
no it just like to to give them
information
yeah and my first reply to you was that
yeah it's not like they have twitter
exactly yes and how do you convert this
data to people that are
in the field working on picking crops
right that don't even have a translation
of what
the word you know a corona virus
actually means
exactly yeah there's all these yes
communication
yes so then then we started like you
know making awareness and all
then later what we realize is like
because of the shutdown
uh everything is closed work is
like you know totally like shut down
because the
the migrants worker actually those
workers they were on the daily wage
means like
if they are working today they will get
paid by the evening
and they will buy the stuff and they
will eat it right and if the work is not
there then what they will eat because
they don't have any food kind of stuff
then what they will do they will pack
their bag and they will say like oh
we left our children at home i mean in
our village so we had to go back
and we need to take care of them so they
just put they just packed their stuff
they uh migrated from wherever they were
working to their home
which is like 500 kilometer which is
like you know thousands of kilometer
from
east to west and you know central to
other places
so these kind of migrants they start
moving
on barefoot because there was no
transportation
and march is a kind of a starting of
heat
which is like 40 40 is like
you know 105 110 temperature was rising
and you can see like how these people
will go because there's no water
and most scary thing when villagers they
came to know
hey there is a virus so that means you
don't
you don't have to like you know uh you
don't have to go to another village
but also you need to uh stop all those
foreigner like foreigner means other
village
other community people entering in your
village and mostly
roads they passes from the one village
to another village to something
and they cannot carry like 10 days water
on their han
on their like you know shoulder so they
had to go to the village to get the
water
food or something but unfortunately
everything was closed
no helping hands and on the top of that
there was a police
who was beating them who was scaring
them and all that so all this chaos
happening so we were what we did is like
we were trying to that's this migrants
distress
yeah yes you can see the first picture
on the left side
they i mean i was passing from there and
i saw
like 15 20 people on the white bag they
had their stuff like clothes
food maybe something else and they were
they i when i stopped my car they
thought like some
officials came and they will arrest us
but then when i stopped my car i said
hey
i'm here to help you listen to me i mean
you know
what can i help you guys and they said
we didn't had a food last two days
because we are walking
i mean they had a children's very very
small children's and and
they were also walking where food so
then what we did is we took them to the
safe place
we just you know uh told them like hey
here is the food you can cook
you can park for yourself and we are
arranging
from the border because all the borders
district water was closed
i mean you cannot enter from one border
to another water so like my village
uh is kind of a on the on the border
from the next district
so we drop them there and then from
there we
we had other friends who were also
helping these people we call them and
make sure
these people will land it safely there
so then when we were helping such kind
of in our own car
which is high risk of you know you are
you may get uh
covet from them or or or you can give
them a covetous short of confusion
because early time like we didn't know
how covet is coming right
and we also knew like the most of the
kovaid or these
these are like you know the patient came
from the international cities
like for example like china buhari to
maybe somebody landed in mumbai and
mumbai person gave to
thousands uh more and those people they
landed in smaller cities
and those people landed in another small
so this this is how
kovit was traveling right one place to
another but
in the march at least these people were
safe
and villagers were safe but because of
that
fear was there which is because of that
this misinformation was there on a
social media or wherever
that everybody was scared like i was
treating you
you as like you know you had a covet
because there was no test available
you cannot test like you have a covert
because it was very limited it was kiosk
everywhere
so then everywhere was everybody was
assuming that okay i may have covered
you may have
covert you are my enemy i am your enemy
something like that
it's like very very confusing situation
so everybody was treating them as a
as a as a not with the kindness but the
victim yeah yeah so then in that
situation what would you do like you
you will definitely try to help them you
definitely try to accommodate them and
make sure they at least should reach
their home
and that was then in a very early time
uh
uh beginning in in a in a april
and then when this star when the first
lockdown it was like
uh i think it was first week or two
weeks and then later they
they keeps extending they keeps
extending so lockdown
stay home order is not like here here at
least if you have some emergency you go
you take your car you go
police won't stop you i mean cop they
will say why are you going you say like
i'm going to take a medicine
but in india it was opposite if you say
you need to show prescription if it is
not up to
date they will they will take your car
they will you know
probably they if you are not wearing or
not like you know uh following their
instruction they will
they may beat you to stop to stay at
home which was kind of a
good good in a way that you're stopping
spreadness but
it is not a kindness like you know if
the person needs something
they cannot go to store only the medical
store was open
nothing else was open no food store not
everything was going in the black
so black means like you know i mean in
the small community you know each other
if you uh close the shop
but then you you had to help other
people because you are not that
bad person you you want to help like all
the villagers so you will give in
some other way like you know other other
door or something like that
so this was sort of things was happening
and later we realized no people really
need a help
now we need to deployed our team we need
to ask for more volunteers
and luckily uh all the big cities
students who were working in a tech
companies who were working in some
offices
they they came back to the home which is
the village because they
belongs to the village so those kids and
students and worker staying at home and
they thought like
what's going on we should help people so
they they came with us
we made a big team and then we went to
the village to village
finding out the older community older
community means like if the older couple
is
living in some house if they are taking
any medication kind of like
sugar or blood pressure or heart or
anything
they cannot get the same medicine when
when it is like you know
uh over because they they had to go
ultimately their uh transportation was
closed
so they cannot go they had to stay
without the medicine for
so many days so we find out such people
such
such older people and they didn't had a
food because they didn't ran out of the
grocery
they can't like you know go out because
because
there are restrictions police was you
know beating or some kind of
rumors around the area so these families
handicapped diseased people means like
those who have a cancers or other big
diseases
they were just you know very miserable
that they cannot have even a painkiller
so we we find out such people such
families
a nearby area we deployed our team
uh we delivered the dry russian
which means like the grocery and what
grossly
is like it includes it includes like a
basic uh
meal so that they can at least prepared
in their house means wheat lentil
and some indian spices some masks
sanitary pads for the women's and
medicine if they need so this kind of
packages we made it and then we deploy
we started deploying in the in the
villages like
uh like um uh these like
yeah so for the migrants worker uh
because they were
going miles and miles they don't have
shoes so we also
gave them a shoes because it was a heat
and they were
they were going uh in a very rough trail
so
sometimes they had a cut on their feet
sometimes they had a
thrones in their their you know feet so
you had to see those people and
especially the kids so we also
arranged like this kind of stuff and
then start giving them
and and and we also have seen like
because there was a
big scarcity around the area and they
knew like here is the police here is the
police
so what they used to do the migrants
worker who were
taking their stuff on the head they
follow the river trail
so what happened is like the river trail
goes and
goes uh miles and miles
which can uh connect to the another
state or another city
they were not taking the road uh because
of the scarcity
because police was there so they were
taking the river trail
which is like it's kind of you are
walking in a
death valley i mean miles or miles you
can go but you cannot find a water
any food or anything so so we
find because we live in the bank of
river
narmada and the river so there were we
were seeing a lot of people
and they used to walk in the dark night
so that people will not see them
they walk they start walking around
seven o'clock in the evening
up to five o'clock in the morning and
day time they will find some kind of
tree
so that they can take a rest and then
again the evening they can start walking
so this kind of this kind of scenario
happening there
and we have seen from our eyes i mean
you know
you you cannot sit at home then we
started
you know finding such families peoples
50 peoples together sometimes 40 peoples
together
and make sure they will have enough food
for five days 10 days something like
that
and we are also connecting other uh
people who were living in a other
other district so we can only we were
limited because we are not supposed to
go to the another
district so we can only help in our
district
and then we had other friends volunteer
groups
they were working their own so we
connect them like hey this group is
coming
you need to take care of them so they
take scare and then they also forward to
other
other uh state so this is how the
collective
efforts of so many peoples and in like
in a community in india
work together in this school with time
and when the
after the third lockdown
when pm announced like hey now you can
take out your vehicles
yeah so one more thing is like we cannot
take our car
like my car i cannot take because you
know
i didn't had a permission to take out
then what we should do
like we used to have those motorbike in
india like we call it motorcycle
so we used to carry like uh 50 pounds or
maybe 100 pounds
on those motorcycle and 5 ten volunteer
views to go
and carry that that bag i mean i used to
go uh with those bikes
motorbikes and this is how we used to
reach out to the people but that also
you cannot
keep more stuff so then when they
announced like a
third lockdown where you can take out
your car and you know
just go for essential stuff then we
started
uh helping more people on the highway
so what we were seeing like there was a
big chaos big news that migrants worker
are dying on the road without you know
food or without water
and some of them they were hiding you
know what the cemented machine
you know the cement mixer machines yeah
because of you know uh they had a fear
like a police will caught us or
something
so they went under the mixer machine
and they were hiding there just to reach
their home
and some of the truck driver or truck
owner
they were so kind that they took a risk
that hey
we can drop you like you know it's just
like you are going one straight to
another state
so people were helping but they were
hiding in a very circ
very tough situation like hiding under
the grains uh
bags like quintils of something and then
they were suffocating in there
they were suffocating in some other
stuff so this
is kind of things were happening so then
what we did is like they were passing
and walking through the highways
so we put this this is the biggest uh
you know the camp
that we ever did uh we were there for um
over a month
and we used to cook a food for the
thousands of people
and here we organize like everything
like the the meal
the dry snacks and also the slippers
and most important is electrolyte packs
because you know they can they can leave
few days without the food but they
cannot live without the water
and which was like you know may
april may time was a was a really high
heat
so at least if they didn't had a food
they can have electrolyte
and you know keep them hydrated
and also the biggest thing is like when
we see the babies for like
four months five months they cannot eat
a spicy food they cannot eat
adult food and the mother is lactating
and she didn't had a food then she
cannot give a food to the baby
then what we should do then we also made
like some kind of cyrillac
which is out of we we call it in local
language is a
sattu so sattu is basically mixture of
the
the this chickpeas
and also the sweet
and that is very very healthy because
you drink more water and
it keeps you like a cold and also it
keeps you hydrated
so that you can mix with the sugar or
some sweeteners
and you can give it to the children's
who are like you know who can't eat
the big meals so this is how we made we
find out like you know figure out like
how to help like everybody out of them
so so our volunteer used to go early in
the morning i used to go early in the
morning
we used to cook entire like a big
dish which is like you know we used to
make kind of um
what do you call it it's kind of like
you make a cereal but with the
vegetables and
and more grains so more nutritional so
that they can have like taste and also
the healthy and then this this goes like
um over a month
and then we also find see in the tribal
area there is no road
so when there is no road but the
families are living there
and they cannot go to the market so what
we did is like
we took the the stuff on our hand like
in our
shoulder and then whatever they need we
used to give them on the top of the
hills
they are actually the tribal who are not
exposed to the main community
they they just live their life they are
happy in their own zone
they don't need like outside stuff they
just need the very basic stuff but which
was also not there
so then we find find out these people
because
the uh any vehicles like car is not
there
is this something like these areas
are reliant the rural areas are reliant
on the transit of
some of the fresh water or
food or basic other needs
clothing technology educational things
these types of things
and that due to the pandemic that those
goods were shut down from being able to
be received
by them in the rural areas yes yes and
so
then basically there was an
infrastructural
gap that was created
because the existing infrastructures got
closed down and now there's
this gap that you know it used to be
there but now it's no longer there
so people aren't getting their basic
needs being met anymore
so sometimes you don't we don't even
realize that by creating these
shutdowns in ways that we actually
create these gaps that then starve
people of their basic needs that they
were receiving because they're located
in rural
areas usually we only think of the metro
areas
on the top priority these millions of
people that live in the metro areas but
the millions of people that live in
rural areas
you know if there's no roads especially
and there's no cars
for the in that they own to be able to
drive out and if
the police are stopping people that are
driving then we're creating this again
massive chaos absolutely and so then now
it requires like non-profit efforts to
be like what about these starving people
right now because you've shut everything
down like what are we doing about that
absolutely
even the government was trying their
best but they they never realized these
consequences
after the lockdown they were totally
unaware
like what will be the outcomes when we
do this
lockdown because kovid may not take
these many people
but hunger and this shutdown will
definitely take at thousands of people
and which was i mean we have seen like
people were dying on the road people
were dying on the
you know uh in the different locations
even
the factory was closed but the owner
they don't want to
send them to their home because their
factory and their buildings and the work
will be
limited or may be stopped they will go
bankrupt so what they were doing
they were hijacking those those labor
like hey we are locking down you
you cannot go there and those labors
they were like 20 people in one room
they were just you know
uh it's like prison more than the prison
actually prison you get some
some at least uh stuff but it was more
than a prison
and the other thing is like the train
they
had like special train or something from
the south to the
uh eastern india which the big
giant people means like you know this
nexus they were stopping the train
otherwise all the laborers they will
migrate to their own hometown
then there will be the biggest this
labor
crisis will happen which ultimately shut
down their
business their buildings infrastructures
their
you know whatever the township they are
making or whatever they are
so these kind of stuff also happened so
the thing is like
here there is a system i mean i i'm not
sure if
this works in a village or interior area
or not but
at least if you have money you can just
deliver online you have internet
instacart or amazon or so many things
but in india if you if you do that first
of all you don't have money
and if you do so you don't have internet
if you have internet then
they will not reach out to you because
impossible because
they are living in their their own zone
so such a
such kind of areas they were like not
even aware of it and most important like
the people who had some kind of very
rare disease or some like you know some
some had a cancer some had some
operations some had some
other issues they were suffering more
because they were running out of their
medication they were running out of
their visit to the doctors
and the hospital and all the private
hospital they were shutting down
all the doctors who were doing private
practice
during that shutdown they were sitting
at home even the government was not
using them because
only government people can work which is
which is again like a
disaster like how can you say like
health worker front liner
you you had to shut it i mean you had to
stay at home they are the one who will
save the people but because the
government system uh did so so they had
to follow the rules so
for some weeks like few weeks they were
at home
all the times they cannot go out so so
in a way it's like
it's like very different from here i was
not here so i don't know what happened
here
but then this is like what i experienced
when i was in india
yeah the the explanation that you're
giving
of what the uh the quote
untold stories of what happens when you
create lockdown scenarios that then
affect
rural areas that nobody ever thought
were
was going to happen and there you go so
again it's kind of interesting to see
all of the different
dynamic adaptation that happens on a
planetary level
when decisions like this are actually
passed along because it is a
massive planetary learning experience
and in a sense it is the adaptation and
the adaptive ability of the planet
to be able to figure out well how do we
become
the kings and queens of biology how do
we
understand the code of life at a level
of star trek
so that we don't even have issues like
this that even arise in the future
and catalyze so much but it was really
important it was a massive learning
lesson on a planetary level
albeit it created a tremendous amount of
suffering and chaos it was still an
incredible learning experience for us
and we will adapt and become even
stronger
but you're right there's all these
untold stories in the rural areas that
you're sharing with us that tsukarma was
able to go in and help alleviate a lot
of the problems too
this next part is probably my
it's probably my favorite part of
what sukarma's doing because it's
basically
you know the tedx talk that you gave and
also the
the whole padman phenomenal that
happened and then maya
is like pad woman phenomenon now
and it's fascinating because it's
something that is a part of it's almost
like
for every single young
girl that ends up becoming a woman in
the world
they go through this it's like a kind of
being baptized into what it's like to be
a woman in a sense to have a menstrual
cycle and to undergo this process of you
know well this is how what it's like
biologically to
end up going through the process of if
you choose to have a child
and that this is what it looks like and
it's
a deeply like spiritual process to
undergo that every single month and it's
very taboo
in many ways and so it's very important
to like help
it so that people don't have like mental
health issues while they're going
through
stuff like this and so that they feel
very comfortable like that's why you
know this is now no tension
is this brand name yes it's like no
tension like let's just open up
and be vulnerable and transparent and
fun and authentic
about talking about this if you don't
have a sanitary way to handle your
menstrual cycle
let's find and give you a very sanitary
safe healthy way to do so and so that's
kind of been
one of maya's biggest points that she's
been doing
and she you actually you guys actually
created a min a new mini factory
yeah yeah so let's yeah walk us through
um
the new mini factory and its influence
yeah so earlier as like sukarma started
with this
project which was my own issue as well
as i said in in our earlier videos the
journey
which belongs to me which close to me
which very intimate to me
i really want to solve that issue in
india in a rural in a
tribal area which i started from my own
area
because i'm the girl from that
village who lived there who experienced
those things
who you know got her periods in those
areas
and experience all those methods
traditional methods and then
somehow end up in a science kind of
backgrounds and study
science and moved here in california so
so when i go back i always see like all
those girls and all those women
are still same i mean same means they
may progress in
so many ways like they may have
smartphone they may have like
other devices other stuff but they
cannot upgrade their own hygienic stuff
which is like something uh it it bothers
me
and it bothers me in terms of like when
they come up with some kind of
infections
some kind of you know bothering like for
example the girl
if they are going to school and they are
sitting six hour in the class
which is way more like impossible that
they can sit
comfortably with the piece of clothes
because first of all they will have
always fear like hey
this may leak any time we will have a
spot
anytime on our back and we may we may be
humiliated in in next
minutes so this kind of uh if trauma if
they are caring entirely in their class
how they can study so there is in india
it is a it is a report says like 12
percent girls
they drop out from school because of
they don't have toilets or this hygienic
uh stuff in the in those areas
yes yeah i can imagine that story that
you're painting of
you know being there and just kind of
like well
you know if i'm don't have the proper
sanitary pads to deal with this
menstrual cycle i'm going to be
completely embarrassed
you know and traumatized by the
experience yeah this
these are very there's like this one is
so
important to tackle and it's such a
simple one to tackle to make
enable more young girls to stay in
school
and to not have those mental health
traumatic experiences that are again
just so
it's a very important yeah and
and this is basically uh inhibiting your
growth
and your life which means if you are
stopping your education
you are ending up the marriage like if
you are 12 13 year old
you're not going to school you will get
married
next year and then next year you will
have kids
and then more next year you will have
three four more kids
so by the age of 18 or 20 you have four
kids one by one and your body is not
even
even even the prepared it is not healthy
it is not like you know grown enough to
handle all that pressure
and where you end up is just like in the
labor work
or some kind of you know the family
stuff or some traditional kind of
so i mean here what i want to say is
like
the simple things in these simple uh
what you call like innovations or or
productions or or a material
can change your life that's for sure so
that's what we did is like earlier we
had like we started in 2017
our first unit sanitary pad
manufacturing unit
which was at the very small area and we
realized like
no we need a really bigger place because
now
we have like more people are coming more
demands are there
and more important like we have a more
worker
they want job because in what happened
is like in
in india we don't have many jobs for the
um the women who are not in college or
you know not finish their high school
they are just you know simple worker so
what we did is like um
we we also want to employ these women we
also want to train those those
uh kind of uh needy stuff and also like
we really want to make sure they will
get their income and also these hygienic
things
so we started uh working with those
groups and women's
so we hired like the big place and and
then we started making more
pads and and that is actually in the
main city area
so that can serve more more uh women and
that will also attract more
population that hey this this is
manufacturing here we should get it from
here
so it's like more communities stuff that
we
we started this year i mean last year
and and we become like you know more
helpful
in this pandemic because as i said
either the whole story
of migrants laborer they were going one
place to another place
think about like those women were not
drinking water
in an entire journey for so long why
because they had to go for a uni
urination
and they know this driver won't stop
this this
truck or bus or whatever if if he or she
won't stop
then you know we can't go for for like
you know for a washroom
so then they were they were not drinking
water and on top of that if they are
menstruating
then where they will find the piece of
clothes where they will find
a information a kind of a pads
so what we also included during this uh
the food that we are giving the material
that we were giving
we were also giving the sanitary pad
where they were using or not using they
can use maybe later
they can use maybe you know they can
give it to somebody
but they must have at least sanitary
pads
with them because they've been traveling
maybe 15 more days
from here to their actual village and
also
we we knew the drivers because they were
transporting
from border one border to another border
so we find out such
driver truck driver or bus driver we
also give them
a box of the pads like hey just keep in
your bus
like the bus you uh where you see all
those migrants worker
if you feel like there is a women or the
girls just give them for free
at least they will have some some
something with them so that they can
help each other maybe they may not
need now but somebody else need they may
not have that part
at that time so this is also a kind of a
very helpful
during this pandemic that we have given
so many pad
for free in all those communities like
in in our district
and the people who are coming from east
to
west india and also going to the eastern
part
rural bihar orissa calcuttas
now and other other places because those
are the places where
they had like most the migrants labor
they go they deployed in
entire country for the work
yeah and the numbers i think you were
saying
in one of the notes was something like
500 000 sanitary pads have been
manufactured since for the operations
first began in november 2017.
yes yes it was like the the
manufacturing and distributions and
we are also helping in some kind of
nature
nature calamity which is like flood like
uh
other stuff so yeah everything is like
going together
yeah let's pull that up so we
yeah i really like the brand that
no tension is a great way to market it i
love that
it's actually really deeply resonant for
me
as well it's just like again just taking
the
all of the taboo out making it really
fun and authentic and transparent and
vulnerable
and easy to chat about and just getting
the sanitary pads in for
the young girls and making it easy again
just the simplicity
of of knowing that this is so important
and it's just a simple thing it's just
making more intimate to them like it's
their personal
things yeah yeah sure
and then
this was around some of the community
classes that you were teaching me about
which was awesome i also didn't know
that this was a
this was happening which was hiring
local teachers
yes so what happened is like uh uh i was
there for like
uh january to september in india and i
was i feel very lucky even the luckiest
person
because i end up being there if i'm in
bay area i may not uh
able to deliver all these stuff so what
i have realized is like you know
those kids who were going to the
government school
everything shut down like government
school close private school close
but then they later realized this
lockdown is extending
so private school they started like just
like here they started online classes
they started
uh teaching on whatsapp or some zoom or
some other other
platform but what happens when you don't
have internet and computers
right again yeah so the government
school
they are already like we all know like
underprivileged kids they mostly go to
the government school
so those schools they were they were
closed and those kids
they just you know they were like they
have no idea when when to start
this school again and then they were
just playing going here and they're
passing their time
so we have seen like so many kids they
are just you know i i
i feel this is more natural way of
learning
but still like you know they should keep
up what they have they
they've been doing in the class so then
what we we
started is like first of all we started
uh
opening a one learning multitasking
center
which is also a store room for our
sanitary pad exclusive store
keeping the sanitary pad because that
town which is a sign cada
nearly closed by more than 50 villages
50 villages
around that area the the villagers comes
to get
all the materials and other shoppings
and other other stuff
because you know that is kind of a small
town so
ah then we we made a stock room so that
the the pads they can get the easily
they can enter in the office and then
first there they see oh
this is the pad box which is very
elegant way that they can relate hey
this is not no more taboo because they
are selling it and
and this is what this office belongs to
like sukarma foundation no tension pad
and this is women things because we
don't talk about it like we are not open
open in in terms of like these sanitary
pads or any women hygienic stuff
so then we we started you know uh
keeping them and also we realize there
is a like the computer
learning is is somehow uh lacking in
that area means like
if the kids they knew the computer they
can do their own
own homework they can do their you know
own stuff if they have a computer
so what we did is like uh we had we
uh kept some laptops and we hired the
computer teacher
that they will teach all those girls
women's
kids who really need a computer basic
literacy like you know
how to make a spreadsheet word file
internet how to pay their bills online
how to
handle this bank accounts online and all
that those are very handy stuff
so they start coming and they start
learning and then we also started like
this this uh
community class which means like uh in
the community there may be
uh 30 students and they don't know how
where to go and how to
read that because they don't have cell
phone their their parents they are
laborer
or they are you know just just living
there and and not like you know very
wealthy so then uh our teachers
they go in that area and talk to the
some community members like hey can you
give us a space because
we don't want to bring your kids uh in
our center so that otherwise they will
get infected means like they have high
risk of corona so it's better we will
come to your place with
all the safety like mask and sanitizer
and we will teach them here in locally
so they give us a place
and we started like basic learning basic
homework
and then all kind of all grades of up to
12th grades
so our teacher they go and they they
they
uh they are there for a whole day like
in shift wise
and then they teach those kids so that
programs went really well
because even now they i mean in our
india
in india march uh february march is the
exam time and we are about to
to uh heading that that time and and if
they are not going
uh school or not reading any books or
not doing anything
then they may not you know go to the
next class
and then ultimately they will leave the
school because they are not passing the
class and they will feel bad in the
community
so this is kind of a new initiative we
started
in 2000 like uh 20 during the pandemic
and more more kids are coming uh more
children's are joining and more parents
are coming in
and asking like hey our kids really want
to go in your class how do we send them
and all that
so this was really i mean it feels me
like really very very
uh kind of connectings and educating and
motivating also because
the the kids who were living like those
who migrated from the city to village
remember the college uh kids or college
students or worker who were working in
the tag
they can also take your classes there
they can use their time if
effectively effectively so the solution
was bringing online education into rural
areas
yes absolutely interesting and then
there was also
a similar situation with floods and sort
of the way that the continued
assistance and relief of whether it was
the basic needs being met or the
education being met or the basic shelter
being met and that was some example that
we were going through a little bit
earlier as well
yeah there's a lot of different prongs
that you're tackling from
well well i would i let me put it this
way
like 2020 was really a disaster here
i mean we were shorting out this uh
covet things and
and this work and this relief but at the
same time we were also knowing the flood
is coming to
each of us home and wiping like
everybody's like you know basic stuff
like
forget about the crops like the crops
those farmers they were growing they all
gone but
those who are living in a downside
non-hilly area they were submerged under
the water
in august month of august i was there
and our village is
surrounded by the biggest river is a
narmada
which is equal to uh ganga river
and also uh sub sub rivers like small
rivers like dudi
and other rivers they were there so what
happened is when the flood came
the water goes like rivers in in the
villages
so most of the villages they are and
submerged for some time
and then those those people because we
don't have prediction like here like
here
if the any storm is coming you will get
at least 24 hour
uh notification and your rescue team
deployed to save people
at least whatever is your material is
going don't worry about it we'll take
care of you we'll take you to the same
place safe place
but in india no it's not like that i
mean the flood came mostly in the night
and they were sleeping and when they
realized hey there's a flood coming okay
let's go
to somebody's house because those who
are living on the uphill
so they just saved there somehow their
life and then they they just went there
and some of them
they have mud house and all that so that
is all
vanished and then they didn't have food
everything is wet
and the school is submerged in the water
the all the records they went like you
know they wiped away
and some of the animals you know the
animals in the clouds and cows yeah
those are very important yeah they were
not like here
uh they were like they were tied with
something
like chain or something yeah so even
even they want to run they cannot run
because
they were tied with the chain or some
some rope so they just you know they
were there and then in the morning you
see they all died and or
they may just you know float flood with
this this um
this water so this kind of this kind of
things were happening so we thought like
okay let's help them too because
you know it's all community efforts more
people are coming more people are
helping yeah then administration also
they are trying to deploy it and helping
the rescue team there
so we were getting calls so many calls
like here and there like hey we
really want help and help and help so we
also
also helped in in this like uh
like the clothes didn't had it so then
whatever you had left at home or
whatever people donated to us we just
sent them because this was the perfect
time to give them nothing
nothing more you can do than giving them
very essential stuff like including food
food clothes uh lights and and all that
basic stuff
yes yeah there's a fascinating
amount of layers that go into the
conversation about the nature of reality
which we'll talk about a little bit
after we get through some more of the su
karma foundation's progress
but just one of the ideas is that the
whole thing with
you know a year being negative
is just it's a funny thing because in
one perspective it's absolutely true
in one layer like a year that has a lot
more suffering
is a worse year because we want to move
towards flourishing
right we also understand that that's a
very dualistic
perspective and the non-dual
teaching on another layer says that
everything's absolutely perfect exactly
the way it is
and that that's sort of a transcendent
eternal style perspective
and so it's just interesting to always
cut
reference these layers as we have the
conversation
because they enable us to see it from
multiple perspectives
as
as we're going through the process
so another critical
component to this that i actually also
didn't know was actually a problem
globally is that
that's actually being solved through a
really cool technological process
which is that the metropolitan areas
have 75 percent of the doctors but 75
of the patients are in the rural areas
which is pretty interesting
wow yeah that's true actually because
most of the population i mean the
the needy and uh uh rural population 80
percent uh
in india they are in the village
actually the population that's so
interesting that
and i wonder if that statistic carries
over in you know china and
us and other places as well but that's a
really really important that that's
being currently
solved through in this case you know you
guys with telemedicine and basically a
lot of the other
institutions and organizations around
the world are realizing that that's a
massive part of our future
is whether it be telemedicine or whether
it be tele-anything
is just in general being able to get
linked up with an expert
on video and soon to be in the virtual
and
augmented reality environments is just
a lot more frictionless and a lot more
location agnostic and all this type of
stuff
and so it's almost in a sense 2020 is
getting
humanity more and more ready for the
virtual and augmented reality
era where there's like less location
based processes and more location
agnosticism so people from around the
world can more easily be able to
collaborate and do things together like
in this case
where people need their basic patient
needs be met they can
phone in the a doctor that's in the
metro areas
so yeah so that's a oh yeah and that's
that's the
that's the wrap of the of the newsletter
yeah so uh we talked in the last video
was like this
project telemedicine was in progress
when i came the
in our first session that time like two
years back
yep so just like uh menstrual hygiene i
realized like healthcare is
also a big problem in that that area
where i was working
so then we then in a in a one conference
i saw
uh there's a conference in bay area uh
taikon
which happens like every year it's a
very big tech conference
for asian community indian community
i've seen there like a one
booth where they they were displaying
this tele medicine
and how these telemedicine clinics they
were working in india remotely
i was very fascinated four years ago
when i saw that i said wow
this is amazing this is what we want
something in the rural area because we
had a hard time to find the doctors in
in our area so then i told them like i
mean i asked them like
what do you need like what is the
minimum requirement you have
and they said like you know what you
just need a electricity and 2 mbps
internet speed so which is like
electricity you can produce through
solar because we are you know all sunny
uh indian most of the time we are sunny
but then how about internet so then
slowly a year later
i saw like there was a mobile tower
which is like geosignal
tower we can see like our phone and our
like this internet is working then i
contacted same people like hey
in my village we got like internet now
can you come and set up that uh
clinic kiosk in our village they said we
don't work with the independent like
individual
small non-profit we work with the
government with the big mass scale
like corporation kind of i said we are
solving this problem serving the
humanity
and you have to do with that i mean you
have to work with us and they were
agreeing like okay
we'll do one clinic in your place so
they started in
in um in a like two year back almost two
years back
they started in our village and we
didn't had any big
hospital if anybody gets sick and they
need to go to civil hospital
which is 100 kilometer from our place
and there's no public transportation so
mostly people they end up like suffering
at home or when they have time or the
transportation then then only they will
go
so this problem at least they solve at
the primary
level so then people are coming like
every day
like farmers they are working in the
field and somehow they have cuts
in their hands or or in the legs they
can come and get the
the first ad and also like this so
basically this tally medicine
is is a complete kiosk setup which
is uh they have a computers i mean
computer with uh
cameras and and they have a basic vitals
like uh
uh ecg blood pressure your oxygen level
your weight and
sugar test and and short of like the
basic vitals that's good where
you need uh i mean your doctor needs to
identify your
your like you know the problem diagnose
the basic problem
and everything is interconnected means
working in the real
time like whatever you are you are
inserting
through the tab the doctor can see that
and everything is interconnected where
all the medicine list doctor also have
it and we also have it
so there is a vending machine like
medicine vending machine you can see in
the pictures
on the back so the doctor is seeing the
patients
and we also employed like a two girls
from our village
they were educated like they were they
went to college degree in biology
but they didn't head job because we
didn't had any company around
so we trained them in a way that they
can become a health care
worker and they can serve the community
so they they learn very fast and we also
hired the practice nurse practitioner
who can give a drip and then nebulizer
and then
you know give all kind of medication to
the patient
so all these three women or girls they
are running the entire clinic
they are communicating with the doctors
and when the doctors
identify the sim cis symptoms because in
india what happened is like
mostly people when we go to the
government hospital
everything is on paper so when we write
everything on paper
then they come home and then they lost
that paper and
two year back when they go to the doctor
they said like do you have any allergy
do you have anything they don't know
anything yeah versus electronic medical
records
so they don't have any records but in
this one they have
all the records when they come after 20
years they have mrna numbers awesome
that
then we keep that now and also the
medical vending machine is so
interesting too yeah so so they can walk
in any time
and after 20 years later they can come
and say hey
mrn number okay you had these medi just
like us here
and even here it's still a [ __ ] show on
the electronic medical records business
yeah but it's still
basic thing at least doctors knows your
study they can
uh study ahead of your time when by the
time you yeah
if the data interoperability is there
which a lot of the time it still
isn't and they still have to ask you the
same questions exactly yeah yeah
yeah so so in a way like those people
they have all the record history and
you know they have allergies or some
kind of like our area
is mostly like tobacco area means like a
lot of people they chew
tobacco tobacco and also like you know
um
other stuff like um not drugs
but alcohol is certainly it's it's
everywhere so basically the
women the most important the women can
walk into our clinic because they are
not dependent
on the mens who can take them to the
hospital or you know
find the extra time so they can come and
get the their treatment they can come
get their drips
and and you know if they have any other
issues like women related issues the
gynecology come
specialists will come and guide them if
they have another severe
stuff then they can refer to the
district hospital or any other city
if they have previous report these girls
they can scan that report
send it back to the doctor doctor can
study and send
send the better medication for that and
also like this
everything as i said everything is
interconnected so after the
the diagnosis and the treatment there is
a
prescription will come through the
printer and which has a barcode
so the barcode when they scan in the
machines all those medical
medication the doctor described they
will come out and patient can collect
and they can go to home within 15
minutes so it is kind of a very very
convenience for for all these this is a
very advanced
technology stack for a rural
village in india yeah the middle of
nowhere this is a really advanced
technology stack yeah
absolutely so during this
leap frog exactly like leapfrog a bunch
of old technology stacks like whoop
just jump right to the cutting edge of
telemedicine
yes so i'm i'm i'm uh uh
i just want to i i just want to give a
more detail during this pandemic
what happened is like as i said all the
private practice
was closed doctor was sitting at home
and only the government hospital was
open during this
first or second or third lockdown so
what happened is
like all those uh patient
who were like you know um want to
have another another stuff like you know
let's say they have
some diabetes or something they cannot
walk into the doctors because
they are not taking any more because you
are at the high risk uh
to get the covet because it is like
highly sensitive area
so then what they will do i mean they
they cannot wait for two months three
months for
for like you know sugar test or
something else so then
our our clinic was open during
the whole pandemic and we increased also
the hour because earlier we used to open
like
9 9 a.m to uh 6 p.m but then we started
like hey there is a more need
more people are coming up let's open for
like let's say 24 hour if there is
somebody's coming
in the midnight late night early morning
nobody like we can call
or we extended our hours like 8 a.m to 9
00 p.m
so this is how like we we increased our
time we increased our labor work
we connected more doctors like some of
them from here
my friend because here is day and night
difference so
uh if night uh in india it's a morning
right now so if the any patient is
coming and they are not finding like a
pediatrician or somebody then because
here
the doctors she also get the degree from
the india so they
they can uh give the at least basic
medication
to the kids it makes more sense for them
to be local
telemedicine exactly of course speaking
the language
relating on the culture being in the
same time zone all that absolutely
so then we we try to uh utilize more and
more
that technology uh during this pandemic
i remember one story
there was a guy who he used to live in a
different
uh district i mean we are from a
different district
but our village on the edge as i said
like it's surrounded by the river
so if you go to this area you will come
up in like
let's say this is california and this is
mexico you cannot cross that water
during the pandemic so that guy he used
to come
uh to our clinic he was regular visitor
he had a
two year kid so in the night he started
walking around three o'clock in the
night
i it's it's a morning and he took the
route of the river
and then he reaches six am in the
morning to our home
and when i woke up i said like who is
there and he said
you know i'm walking for three four hour
i took this route because here
police is sitting there i cannot take
that route
and i'm from a different like we know
because these villages are very close
he did that all to come to the tele
medicine club yes yes for his
child right two year old child yeah and
i feel like
what is going on what is going on why is
this so much friction
exactly so that moment i said this
is really worth it that you know if if
we can treat people like him
or people like you know other community
like these kind of stuff
i mean it is so much like we have we
have achieved
like so much it is like i was so humble
to see that this guy he was sitting for
two hour because you know doctor was not
available but still
he want to get treatment he want to get
medication he want to make sure
like you know i will not be in trouble
like next couple of months and then
he will revisit again something like
that so these kind of people who are
really needy
who are really in pain they were
visiting and and you know getting the
treatment
2 500 patients per month
yes yeah at the one clinic yes
wow yeah because it it is like you know
some of them they are coming to take for
the medication some of them they are
coming for uh all of this
yes almost 100 a day so how many
different telemedicine portals are there
in the clinic
how many different stations are there so
stations is like we don't do
uh like the blood testing and drawing
because that is a lot of work and also
the chance of infections
so we send them to the different town if
they had if they need like any
how many of those yeah stations are
there yeah so we have so far like three
station
one is like uh to measure the vital
other is to connect the doctors and
other is to connect
like you know to withdraw the
medications and all vitals doctor
medication and then one is a different
section like uh
covered section for the drip and and
injections
like uh for the women's or whoever is
coming there sure
so these are like four five yeah four
five station that we have it
interesting so it seems like the yeah
the components
are so far the primary ones the sanitary
napkin manufacturing
the no tension brand that's kind of the
most primary one
and then there's the telemedicine which
we just covered the primary health these
are kind of the ones that are going to
continue
right because all the covet stuff was
just because it was the problem
yes and it's probably not going to
continue stuff like that and at least
now we've learned about how to better
handle the
rural areas when things like this happen
but there's still some things that do
with like the whole flooding situations
and stuff like that to be able to more
dynamically adapt and things like that
and to have better communications and
warnings and stuff like that
but so it seems like those two for the
two ones that are going to continue
sanitary napkin manufacturing no
tension brand and then the telemedicine
and primary health
and education also and this is what
we're going to do so
yeah oh yeah and computer education for
the rural areas yeah okay
so the community classes the rural
education is another big one
um and then this one is also
the a critical one which is the building
of the new school so
let's see if if i can pull up some of
those
yeah here's the it's under the
all right so this is the new school the
proposal for the new
the new school a 12 000 square foot
school in your in actually in your home
town it's where you actually went from
grade one to eight yes yourself yeah so
this
this is like the school uh place where
um
the school was there for like uh 60 70
years
because you know my uh father my grandpa
all they went in the same school
uh during this british time but then
over the time we saw these buildings
they got collapsed and then now
the government they just made a one room
two rooms here and there
so in that way like it is pretty much
scared
that is scattered that you know student
can't sit comfortably and they can they
can't uh study
so basically one two ah five students
they are sitting in one room
six to eight students they are sitting
in one room and technically they are not
not learning anything they are just
going school so what we thought is like
how why can't we make a school
with the help of foundations people like
us and also the community support
because if you can show there is a will
there is a way right so then this this
uh
uh if if you work on this kind of uh
efforts you certainly can make it then
we come up with the plan
that how we can make a sustainable
building which can serve our village and
also nearby the village as i said like
it's a
totally remote area and if one family
they want to educate their son or
daughter mostly they they
send their son to the private school
daughter no no because
it's a culture there because they don't
want to spend money on daughter they
want to spend money on sun so that you
know they will be
a support in in their i mean this is
really
i mean this is very very unusual but but
then it's it's really at the same time
it is a culture we need to
accept that that they want to educate
son instead of daughter in a private so
that they will earn money and they will
take care in their older age
so so then what what happen is like one
poor family farmer family they end up
end up paying like 30 000 rupees per
annum on one kid
so imagine like if one family's is a
putting 30 000 rupees
per year on a one kid if they had four
kids
then they can only support maybe two of
them maybe
one of them so all the kids they cannot
go to the private school so this
basically the rest of the fifth more
than 50 percent population in the
village
they won't go and get the college
education right
so then what we thought is like how to
make this sustainable
learning which has everything like the
environment
the public school education better
public school so that the
kids not only learn the computers and
other stuff
they will also learn the livelihood
livelihood means
how to grow their own food because we
are the farmer community
and we are our kids are not learning
even how the wheat look like
how how the rice look like i mean the
the plants look like
how the you know how to grow them if
they don't know about it
then how they will survive you can
survive without computer
but you cannot survive without the food
which is actual part right
so we also need to teach them in terms
of
the food the vegetables the garden and
sustainability when it comes to the
environment because
all together the education is i believe
it's not about earning money it's about
like
running this planet with the equal
efforts
that we take care of all kind of species
totally like waters all kind of animal
elements like the water air uh soil
everything that we make sure we are not
polluting
any of them because they are the
integral part of our
life that's how we will go maybe 200
more years i don't know how long we will
survive on this planet as a human
uh in this kobe time but then these kids
they really need to learn about
like the climate change they need to
learn about this this all kind of
stuff so this is how we want to make the
school
and this is how you know we want to make
the community
i mean this building so that everybody's
kids they can go
and they can be there up to middle
school high school
and after that they can go to the good
college so this is what we our efforts
that
it's it's in a progress we we need to
take a permission from the officials and
it is
the primary plan is done like the
architectural designs and
map and everything if if we get the
permissions and
we have a foreign stick then we can
start building that
so this is like very very you know
important project
for me and everything that's a huge
long-term project
exactly because this is kind of a model
that you want to set
the example that how many how
areas around india and around the world
can prioritize a public school
education for long term yeah
absolutely because because here
everybody goes in a public school which
is it is a taxpayer money
but in india the education is getting
more and more
and more uh corporate kind of stuff like
the
all the big school owned by the
corporate why the politician and it is
becoming like more
money making stuff so there is like you
know they are eliminating the learning
part
but they are making like more money so
poor people like us we can't do
it sounds like the united states jail
system
yeah maybe if you have money you can
send it well no
like our jail system is very much around
making money rather
than you know rehabilitation and around
education and around enlightening
and stuff like that and and in this case
it's
if education is going to become this
corporate machine
that it's also going to be oh actually
united states has their university
system has become like the corporate
machine
of the public school system like you
talk about right now in india
it's at least from your experience and
what it sounds like because the united
states on
again on that very taxpayer level for
the
elementary middle and high school yeah
sure you're right
university wise though it's a joke you
know fifty thousand dollars for some bs
sheet of paper that says whether or not
somebody's qualified to
sit at a cubicle for eight hours a day
clicking buttons on a computer to do
something is an absolute joke that has
nothing to do with enlightenment and has
nothing to do with the eradication of
suffering it has nothing to do with
solving
the sustainable development goals and
maximizing human potential
and all of the kids in india in the
rural areas and all the kids in the
united states and across the world
deserve a very robust non-profiteering
style educational component to their
youth
i it shouldn't have taken me you know 25
years to hear the word sachit ananda
existence consciousness bliss
it shouldn't have taken me 25 years to
understand
that i and my father are one that we are
it that
the nature of our consciousness the
nature of our reality is one with the
divine
that this is absolutely perfect and that
it's unfolding
in its just most indescribably beautiful
way
and that there's just this so much
unnecessary craving
and suffering as you know so many of the
planetary spiritual traditions trying to
enrich us to
have equanimity have imperturbable peace
have causeless joy to have these most
fundamental
principles and to butterfly affect them
out
because that is our true nature is
completely washed
in all of the insanity of the economic
machinery
and all these other components so to
just say it
it's it's permeated across the k
through 12 across universities across
adults
so many adults are just in straight
jackets there's no child like
bliss anymore there's no more childlike
piece it's just egos inside of little
boxes
around their heads and so there's a lot
of components to this
that need a massive flip on their head
uh you know that layer one layer again
within the indescribable perfection is
what we actually want to architect what
we are
flowing the architecture processes
already flowing
through us into the world so
this is probably a good transition into
that conversation
because there's all these components
that you're already doing that are
extremely beautiful with karma
foundation we got to unpack them
but you know you're also very
adamant and very well practiced yourself
in the vipassana tradition the theravada
buddhism tradition
the direct most conservative teachings
of the buddha of the end of suffering
of nirvana of enlightenment of the
eradication of craving and aversion at
the most root fundamental level
experientially in your own
practice and i am as well
and that as we were talking before we
started there's basically many different
faces to this one truth and
whatever face you take or however many
of them you decide to connect
you're going to end up on this one
non-dual
truth and that i'm curious to hear
what profound influence because we
probably didn't get to
uh unpack this in the more enriched
states of being that we're both at now
especially myself after the two-year
period
so let's unpack sort of your thoughts
around vipassana around enlightenment
around non-duality
around the nature of reality
consciousness that type of stuff
yes you are absolutely right because um
my first time i have done vipassana in
2015
and in 2016 this vip this sukarma
foundation bond means i
started uh in india so
when i did first time this vipassana i
realized like
how to channelize your energy
in more effective way because here i
live in silicon valley
which is prime hotspot for anybody's
like you know in terms of job technology
computer making money
one after others they are you know
running like a crazy
and there's no end of it right i mean we
have seen like
most young people most older peoples
they have big mansions
cars and it is just endless and in end
of their life
what they feel like how they uh i mean
how they you if you talk to anybody's
who is like 80 year old and he has
everything if you ask one question are
you really happy
i mean have you achieved what you have
you know thought about
and they may say like yes we have
achieved so much
but you can definitely see and say like
hey
they are not happy because this is not
what they have
done so this this kind of like uh the
happiness
within themself i don't think like that
make
that comes with a money or or a material
totally so when i did this vipassana and
i realized like
the craving that we have inside us or
among us or in the society community
one after other in certain and sort of
that ego you know why we are running
one after after other things because as
as we all know like goenkaji also he was
just a
typical normal uh household
person he also want to earn millions
billions and year and so far
but then end of end of it like when he
realized
this is like craving this is a world of
like
endless craving that you know we
we really want to make everybody's happy
like on the back of uh
ancient times when ashoka he just want
to become like you know big
king of everybody he just want to kill
everybody
uh because he that's the way like that
he can become an
empire and and he can acquire all that
lands or whatever is like
but when he met this vipassana he become
very ordinary very normal very content
person
so i think in my ways like vipassana
when i learned
and when i went first time i realized
like
in this this uh uh what do you call in
in a time there's nothing which is like
a permanent
everything is revolving around you and
it's just like your perspective that how
you see
all those things like you may see like
okay i'm working in google
i may make million uh in in two years or
three years
but what they will what the million will
do
will this make you happy or will this
make you like you know
take you at that another level maybe not
but
this is the kind of a craving inside you
which is pushing you every day
which is which is blocking your i would
say like it's a blind spot that you are
not seeing the other stuff
in your back which is more beautiful
more satisfying
and more like natural around you the
energy
basically so in that way like i i i felt
that like
okay i mean i am as a as a uh
um like myself i came from a village
where i started my life with a zero like
i didn't had anything to lose
all i all those years uh like let's say
in
in these 30 years
i left my home when i was 14 and i went
to
another village to get another education
another another school and college and
all those years i was just one after
other so when i came here i said if i
do this community work
i may not lose anything because you know
all i will gain
is like uh some kind of experience some
kind of
exposure that hey you are also the part
of this community
and if you if you serve these people you
will feel happiness because
you are solving their pain like their
issues their
problems and they are they are getting
better and better and better and that's
how i
i engaged with this foundation and i
mean
started this foundation and engaged all
those work
and i feel like it is very satisfying
that you are seeing people around you
who are who are in a misery like you
know we all
also all all see in vipassana like
people who are in a misery
they they don't know why they are in
there because you know
they didn't have that exposure of
vipassana like in the last person
when when came to the buddha like hey i
really want
enlightenment and by the time buddha
said no my time is over
the guy said no his time is over but
then buddha
came up and said like hey no i mean you
know my
time is not over i may do something good
to him so
there is a always like you know ah
thing and and there is always something
uh
ahead you which you cannot see but there
is a some positive energy which you can
feel and do better work
with your experience with the equanimity
with the
uh the stillness uh realizing
yourself in this like you know in in
this
uh surroundings and and channelizing
that positive energy
around you without uh having any kind of
like ego without having any kind of you
know um
competition or any kind of uh
like any kind of negativity in your mind
and that's how i learned in in a
vipassana that
you know uh there is something that we
are
this this whole uh i think world is is
lacking
which is uh uh i think the the kindness
more empathy and
and and more like you know generosity
that if they can bring in their
own uh practice and their work i think
this this world will be equal
and this is how vipassana taught us like
we need quantity in in everywhere we
need a
it it's i mean vipassana doesn't mean
like you need to sit eight hour and you
do be past now no
i mean you need to bring in your action
you need to bring in next to you
like how can you see this person is
suffering in your way
not his way if you can realize like if
you can see
okay this person really suffering and he
needs certain thing which makes him
happy
or uh you know certainly uh what do you
call is like
uh maybe something which can make him or
her happy
your your goal is is accomplished
because
you can see at least the pain and most
of us we can't see that because you know
we are in
our own illusion world because my name
is maya it means illusion
but i i try to see beyond that because
you know
um i mean something money can't buy
something money can't give
i think we we we really need some some
more enlight
enlightenment uh beyond that which we
can see
see like you know more clear pictures
and more i think
uh depth in our knowledge and whatever
we are doing and
and and surrounding us we can feel that
pain and that energy
for sure so vipassana is something i
have done actually
it is a really good thing um when i went
in january
uh in february uh i applied before like
in november
uh in igatpuri which is the main
vipassana center
in india and that's where the gohenkaji
he started
first time and that place is is magical
like
exactly so i had that like you know in
my mind i should do there because it's
original place and i'm sure
it is much more divine uh than we
thought
you know in in other places so i went
there and i was
10 days vipassana it was completely
different because
you see like so many peoples and and
other people
who may not have a time uh like you know
they can give a 10 days
but they were coming there because they
just want to do and they
they were like you know doing this for a
long time and they
they were happy person it doesn't i mean
you can see
the laborer people they they came and
doing this
vipassana for 10 days some like you know
daily workers some
farmers some it's not like you know the
the people who can afford the time and
where
who have those like resources then they
can allocate and take time off of 10
days and go the vipassana no
very ordinary people who are coming and
doing in
in very very good manner and i've seen
more than that i have seen a lot of
people who were
serving like those thousands of people
with the like you know with the
happiness with the kindness with the
with the with the passion like this is
what i have seen before this pandemic i
think that helped
helped me a lot during all this uh
eight nine months because uh this was
very high stress and turbulence
for for particularly me because my
family
they were very scared in india when i
used to leave
home around six o'clock come back in 12
o'clock in the night
they felt like i don't know what
happening to her like you know she's
just going random places
but for for me it was not that stressful
because
i know what to do i mean you know when
when you do something then you can see
the clear picture your goal your
targeted uh uh spot where where you
really need to be focused i think the
vipassana that's what
uh gave me those those uh paths and
open like you know more ways to help
more people
so i feel this is this is something
which is really helpful in in our daily
practice actually
totally yeah
there may in fact be
just nothing that is so
so important as the
gift that we can render the world by
turning inward turning
inward is the solution and it's been the
solution for thousands of years
and it's still the solution in modernity
and it's just that
the
everything being so outward driven
outward focus
is just so funny it's just the
infinite seeking exterior for happiness
that's just happening and it's like nope
the diamond necklace is around your neck
it is you it is consciousness it is this
this is it you are already infinitely
blissful
and happy and peaceful but the true
recognition of that and the true
embodied sahaja samadhi to be able to
actually carry it with you
weave it the tantric path into the
fabric of life
is it that is it that's how to do it
yet the hilarity
of like the parable of the prodigal sons
just always like
outward outward outward hit a breaking
point okay fine i'll go inward okay
let's see what this consciousness thing
is about
let's see what you know yoga's chitta
vritti
nirodha is about let me see if i can
calm these fluctuations of the mind and
what's revealed to me in the process am
i actually
infinite am i actually eternal is this
actually
is the form actually an illusion is it
actually just a dream what is the
formless what is the
absolute what is the agentless the
attributeless
what is that perfection is this
perfection too
yes it is and to surrender
to that flow of perfection
is it and it's so hilarious
and so peaceful it's so funny it's just
all like
yeah it takes a little bit of uh
time to realize that
that absolutely yeah
yeah just go with the flow it already
is
this and it already is
happening and we are it and it is doing
us
and just flow with that
my i'm so proud of you wow look at all
the stuff that you've achieved
we're good good job thank you so much
it's because all of
us like you know it's not me it's all of
us collective efforts
the donors the volunteers the people
like you
everybody's collective efforts so i'm so
happy that i'm here and
you know again we are discussing all
that things which matters
yeah i'm really grateful you inspire me
so much yeah
you too thank you yeah thank you i
i have a strong feeling that there's
going to be a lot of people that tune in
that
realize at a deeper level sort of what's
going on with meeting basic needs around
the world you know
sanitary pads is usually not something
that people
realize that is something that's just so
simple to be able to
to put the pieces together to be able to
provide for
the basic need of young girls but it's
such a massive contributor to their
flourishing
and and so that one and then the basic
you know the basic health care and
primary care needs of telemedicine is
huge it's so
awesome like the call that you have and
you're like no we're serving humanity
you're gonna help us
and that's so fun that they come
together like that and then yeah remote
education as well now with computers
they're all really strong components and
hopefully you know the rich patrons arm
you know it's not that much you know the
three hundred thousand dollars that it
costs us dollars to build
a school that can last for you know
decades of making profound impact on
young people's lives and then that same
model in the rural areas around the
world
to be unleashed as well in a very
ecologically technologically
self-realization self-actualization
style way
is uh that's so beautiful absolutely
yeah thank you so much for putting all
the efforts
making this wonderful presentation i'm
so grateful
yeah likewise likewise and you had it
already all together in your email blast
you sent like 10 days
ago and so we just yeah we went over a
bunch of that
a bunch of that content absolutely i'm
leaving india again
on 17th you're going back yes
just next week and i'll be there another
four or five months four five months
there you go you're going back
boom just like that yes wow
so this is like 20 21 i hope this will
bring more positivity
more good stuff around us everybody's we
are hopeful
so let's see because people still
suffering from basic
basic stuff there so yeah we can help
more people
wow yeah well
yeah godspeed going back four or five
months is another big chunk of time a
lot to accomplish though for sure
it's exciting and again for everybody
that's tuning in
check out the links in the bio below
again the tsukama foundation
is of taking donations so you can
support
again just suekarmafoundation.org check
it out links in the bio
taking donations across all of their
different endeavors we just signed up as
well as simulation which is really
exciting
love helping out of course we love
helping out our artists
and philanthropists and spiritual
leaders and engineers scientists all
these different people across the fields
you can also link up with maya on
linkedin the links in the bio below as
well
and thank you for tuning in
we greatly appreciate you like the video
if it made a profound impact on you
subscribe if you haven't already leave
us a comment below with some of your
feelings around the episode would love
to hear from you
and also share with people that you feel
would find this impactful influential
and that is all that is all meet the
basic needs of people around the world
such a critical component to you know to
your essence to our essence with
things that we can maximize the
well-being and prosperity
surrender to that flow it's already now
love you all thank you for tuning in
thanks thank you so much thank you
good night good night bye everyone
peace